let's talk about the one person who's
done the right thing Liz Cheney no I'm
kidding uh we have a story from Yahoo
news new poll indicates a Liz Cheney
presidential run would hurt Biden more
than trump it can be uh simply shown in
this chart in this graph right here if
Liz Cheney were to run as an independent
Democrats would vote for her helping
Donald Trump win
and based on this polling they're
actually saying right now and this is
another I don't necessarily believe all
this they're saying right now based on
their polling data Joe Biden would beat
Donald Trump in an election if it was
held today or at least at the time of
this this poll support for Joe Biden 46
Trump's 42 but if Liz Cheney runs an
independent Joe Biden 32 Cheney 11 Trump
40. I would I would be very interested
to know what the poll would say if a
DeSantis were to run endorsed by Trump
and those two I think it would be a
landslide I think he would
um he would do very well people need to
understand too landslides it doesn't
mean like 80 of the general public votes
for the candidate it means like 55 does
and this results in a massive swing in
the Electoral College you end up with
all the states there's a thing you know
people were saying that Trump wanted a
landslide against Hillary he won three
states that got him over and it was by
88 000 votes so that's not a landslide
but industrial College it came out to
like a you know a decent number of
electoral votes that he ended up winning
but the electoral votes are shifting New
York lost two and Florida gained two you
know California I think lost one too
right what yeah when you have these
policies that cause a mass Exodus of
intellectual individuals you know
they're going to find Refuge they are
refugees that's why I try to tell people
when they come from my home state of
Connecticut to Georgia or to Florida
like you are not a prophet please don't
come here with the politics that I left
they were a refugee so they they they do
and it's worse than that they bring
other people with them I I hadn't really
been seeing that in the Southeast I've
been seeing individuals coming there and
and acting as refugees saying hey we are
here because where I left is not good
and it's getting worse because what you
guys have going on in Georgia and in
Florida is better than where I left and
I don't want to mess that up Elon Musk
was in California
people live in California two to one are
Democrats Elon Musk moves to Texas and
opens the gigafactory a lot of these
employees I'm assuming maybe I'm wrong
I'm assuming he didn't fire everybody in
California right probably transferred a
bunch of them that's a bunch of
California progressives being moved into
Austin
so I do think there are more refugees
than there are people transferring
because of work policy
but depending on the size of the
industry and of the individual they
might bring you know for every one high
net worth individual who's like hey I
believe in Liberty and freedom they
might bring 10 woke employees with them
at T moved to Dallas the Dallas area I
think in
2012. I could be wrong on that and they
were based in California pre before that
so they also transferred their employees
out there I mean I think I'm sure some
of the option to leave the company stay
a lot came to Dallas it really blew up a
couple of the suburbs in the Dallas area
and this is prior to Trump being elected
I mean the shift towards pro-business
States has been going on for a long time
it wasn't just covet in politics that
started uh Mass migration of people with
maybe not the political leanings of the
states they were ultimately ending up in
I think Kobe just made it much more of a
intentional choice for some people there
was much more of an examination of the
life you were living because you were
suddenly stuck at home having to
reconsider what you really wanted well
look at the flexibility that people were
able to gain once we realized that you
could work virtually right so
individuals who were working for
companies that can now work at home
chose to not live in a
degrading Society right meaning the the
crime is up the bang for your buck is
down and it only seems to be getting
worse those individuals are the ones
that I see leaving in Mass Exodus
they're not leaving because their
business massive company moved so they
had to move with it they're moving
because they have the freedom and
flexibility to choose to not live in New
York City to choose to not live in LA
and they've decided
um that that's not for them anymore that
they don't want to live in fear of
walking down the street and getting
mugged and raped and murdered because
there's there's lawlessness in La it's
it's like Zombieland my manufacturing
partners are out there and when I go out
there it just gotten worse and worse and
worse it's it's straight up Zombieland
yeah I remember for a while Maine
offered this program or if you're a
remote worker you'd come live in Maine
and get you know I don't remember money
towards a house or a tax credit or
something like that Maine has an aging
population and they don't have a ton of
Industry so they really do want remote
workers to come in and repopulate have
kids have young families obviously mean
it's beautiful lots of outdoor stuff
there is a reason you would want to be
there it's just not possible if you
can't work there and this was way before
covet I mean this was happening again I
think it was like 2010 but at the time
there were not as many remote positions
as there are now I think that we'll
continue to see states with low birth
rate or older populations trying to
incentivize remote workers to come out
out because again
if you can work have a steady job and
work wherever you want you are much more
likely to choose a place that's
reflective both of your political or
ideological volumes but also of a
lifestyle that you want to live
Delaware figured it out Delaware figured
a lot of it out there's a lot of states
that drive business away and it's really
interesting how the economics of this
work if you're an ice cream shop you
register your business in the state
because you're like in the state but if
you do National level business why would
you not be in Delaware
that the tax the the laws the
restrictions the taxes in every state
are are cumbersome so this is why every
corporation not literally every but like
most of them will just open up in
Delaware I think Nevada is another one
and Wyoming is good too but now even
California was leading the charge of how
to ruin their online business and tax
income because right now because of
recent laws last few years uh Wayfarer
versus I think North Dakota oh yeah yeah
and there was that title Title Nine or
whatever the thing was so sales tax is
now collected in all 50 states when you
hit next is threshold right so
California is actually one of my largest
states right we send millions of dollars
of product there sales tax fine I
collect sales tax I give it to you as of
lately now California is saying actually
we want a percentage of our income tax
as well so I'm a Georgia resident I paid
Georgia state income tax at seven
percent which is still higher than zero
which is Florida right I'm sure I could
probably find ways around it and I don't
feel like going to IRS jail or getting
shot for that dude in the wheelchair for
whatever reason you saw the video IRS
tactical training I don't even know why
they have guns but okay so I I have been
told now I'm expected according to
California to pay taxes as if I was a
California resident because I in their
mind I'm a resident I have no physical
property I've never go to the state for
more than 24 hours because I hate it now
because the
beautiful scenery just no offense the
people they're insane so well I mean the
the the climate's bad too like they're
in a drought it's like not showing all
the political environment the uh
discussions the focus of their attention
on what I consider silly things it's I'm
not a big fan and I definitely don't
want to pay 17 still Stacks to a state
that I don't physically go to like it's
I'm it's my company all your Revenue yes
yeah that apportionment of it goes gets
taxed at 17 so obviously I politely
declined and said that according to
federal laws is this and that'll be
another Supreme Court ruling to see if
we now as internet-based companies have
to start paying these insane taxes so I
don't even know how that would work so I
pay 70 tax to California and 12 to
Newark and all this I would have zero
right dollars left over and I don't
understand how people don't get business
right I started my garage I sold my car
to buy my first machine I sold my house
to buy another Machine by the way when
you're deploying a bunch no noticed and
you have a pregnant wife with two kids
and a great danes and you move them into
an apartment that does not they don't
like it they don't like that but you
know it's a sacrifice right so we
continue to sacrifice and put everything
all in and now I'm at a point where the
level of taxes that I pay as compared to
Amazon you know I pay tens millions of
dollars more than Amazon s and that that
is absolutely ludicrous but but it's
obvious why you will owe nothing and you
will be happy
I think that is the plan
um I will always be happy and I think
that happiness is is on you we don't we
don't do any business with California in
any possible way it's a strict company
policy California is state non-grotta
for us whatever however it would
actually be stated and we've had people
who hit us up and like hey we'd love to
work with you or like we we want to
submit an article or we're looking for
work and I'm just like as long as you're
in California there's not a conversation
to be had and it's and and to put it
simply California has laws in order to
just not run a file we just do not do
any operations in any capacity with
anyone in the state of California oh no
I'm being sued right now by a blind man
in New York and another person in
California who's saying that my website
is not blind accessible which it is by
the way for full just you know if anyone
who's listening to this and happens to
not be able to see you can absolutely go
to 911 apparel.com and you will talk to
you just as it's supposed to but anyone
can sue anyone from those States and
they're very Sue
um not happy but I guess they they they
encourage it so I will spend tens of
thousands of dollars on these frivolous
lawsuits in California and in New York
and I won't get a change of venue to
Georgia because they know they won't win
in Georgia and they're just hoping that
these mid-sized companies not they're
not going after Mom and Pop and they're
not going after Coca-Cola right they're
going to go after individuals that they
think have the ability but to pay but
they don't have the ability to kind of
fight it out right so there's hundreds
of thousands of these lawsuits that are
allowed and all they do is just hurt the
bottom line for people like me who you
know I I don't know how to get around it
I don't know how to Advocate I don't
know how to tell people about it because
like you said you know shut down my
Facebook account not national news go
and sue me because a blind person says
they tried to go buy something from my
website
um not a good news story but you know
deal with it and these are the policies
that New York and California are
encouraging and they destroy businesses
and to the point where you know I have
another cup company called hoist that
does military hydration
and they're now telling us that you know
the the product is not in compliant with
California's blah blah blah blah blah
standards I'm not a lawyer right well I
just have to go get different lawyers to
figure out why I could sell to
everywhere else but apparently it's
California has a different standard of
uh consumables what is it that you're
selling with hoist uh hoist is military
hydration so we sell to the government
for uh and make sure our troops stay
hydrated imagine
a drink that I can't say that you were
given when you're really dehydrated you
know as a medical treatment uh
rhymes with media light but it tastes
horrible right so it's like that but
tastes good so we sell it to the
government and then we also sell it to
you now civilian venues like Publix and
Walmart and everywhere else but in
California it's it's getting the same
co-packers same people who make
Coca-Cola products make this product but
they're not going to go Sue Coca-Cola
they're just going to sue hoist or
companies like me it's because of like
label they want like it to say may have
been created in a lab with that may have
had access to lead maybe something like
that had a yes something it's their
title 19 California act that just came
full force a couple months ago it's it's
California they're gonna find some other
way to mess with business and then
complain that they have no income tax
and that they're bankrupt and then the
federal government people need to get
out of California I did I liked it at
first I thought I had to be there
because I was an actor so I thought well
it's New York or La this is like 2005.
and so I in 2006 I moved to Los Angeles
I was in Chicago for a while too and I
lived there for five years I got revs
really depressed I didn't like it it
smelled the the brake dust I I don't
know what but my hypertension was
intense like was up and I left and then
I went back in 2014-15 because I was
like well it's La I'm gonna give it
another shot maybe I'll just but I
realized by that point the internet I
mean I'm working remote I don't need to
be in La I was on the sixth floor and I
didn't drive the Second Time Around
which turned into a whole better
experience but still
it was it was dirty chaos man it's you
got the the ocean there's there's
benefits to it and you're right Ian we
should just move the show to Saint Kitts
and Nevis we should go offshore
uh this show could be done anywhere in
the world I might start working remotely
I love your spot like honestly this is
Middle nowhere this is the chicken This
Is My Jam you got chickens I I get
anxiety when I'm in New York City when
I'm in La when I'm around a large
populated area of mostly angry people
and I understand why you're angry I used
to have to go to school in New York City
it took me three and a half hours just
to get there and then deal with very
angry people who didn't like my all
lives matter shirts except for Isis F
those guys like I would wear it all the
time you know it was funny but it was
during the whole blue lives matter black
lives matter and all these different
lives matter debates and people just
literally would lose their mind and
freak out and I'd be walking down the
street with my large female
African-American you know West Point
friend and calling her an Uncle Tom and
telling me mean things and I'm like I
hate New York City I cannot wait to
leave and I get back to Savannah and
it's just Zen you know everyone is very
nice there's no honking of horns there's
you know it's a it's a different way of
life and the cities are falling apart
man they are yeah it's because of
leadership though because I I'll tell
you New York City
giuliani's a friend uh Bernie Carrick
Police Commissioner in New York City is
a really good friend you know under
their leadership you know during that 9
11 pre-911 Post 9 11 the the crime rates
the the just everything about the city
was so much better and you changed that
leadership and you Watch What Happens
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or or
tune in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there